Republican House leaders may have
overcome one of the biggest roadblocks
to repealing Obamacare the effort failed
last month when a group of conservatives
refused to support it
well now members of that group say
they'll support a revised version of the
American Health Care Act Nancy Cordes is
on Capitol Hill with the changes that
other members might reject Nancy good
morning good morning those conservative
members always felt that the GOP plan
left too many of Obama cares minimum
coverage requirements in place
requirements they believe drive up
premiums well there's a new problem
compromise that they support and that is
a big breakthrough except that some
moderates think it makes the bill worse
certainly now we're down to days not
weeks after weeks of negotiations
members of the conservative freedom
caucus say they are finally ready to
vote yes we're supportive of the
mcarthur amendment in the underlying
bill as it's coming board
Virginia's Dave brat is one member who
came around none of us are going to be
totally happy I'm a free-market guy
there's better ways to move on some of
this stuff but we want the momentum to
go forward to tax reform get the budget
through and all that this is what got
him there a new amendment allowing
States to eliminate some of Obama cares
patient protections including one that
prevents insurers from jacking up rates
for people with pre-existing conditions
those states would be given some funds
to set up high-risk pools to help cover
those who would no longer be able to
afford insurance this is a different
twist and I've got to re-examine it the
twist meant to appease conservatives is
turning off some moderates we have to
help those people that were harmed by
the Affordable Care Act but at the same
time not harm the people that were
helped by it we need to take a step back
Pennsylvania Republican charlie dent has
always been a no and believes this
amendment violates one of the party's
promises well it could affect people
with pre-existing conditions and
it'll make insurance probably much more
expensive for them and in some cases
perhaps inaccessible the question is how
many members will defect GOP leaders
still aren't sure could we see a vote on
health care this week or next we'll see
well vote on it when we get the votes
another sticking point for several
Republicans I spoke to is a provision in
this new plan that keeps those Obamacare
protections in place for members of
Congress and their aides the authors say
it's in there for technical reasons Gail
but they know how it looks and they're
going to try to figure out a way to work
around it
all right Nancy thank you